- [Instructor] In the part
one video, we already saw
James Madison and Federalist number 10.
argue strongly that a
republican form of government
is better for addressing
the issues of having
an majority faction that might try
to overrun minority groups.
In this video, we're
going to continue to see
that argument that not
only is a republic better,
but if you're going to have a republic,
it's better to have a large republic.
In the next place, as each
representative will be chosen
by a greater number of
citizens in the large,
the large republic, than
in the small republic.
It will be more difficult
for unworthy candidates
to practice with success the
vicious art by which elections
are too often carried and
the suffrages of the people
be more free will be more
likely to center in men
who possess the most attractive merit.
Once again, elite democracy,
and the most diffusive
and established characters.
Once again, elite democracy.
So here, he is making the
argument that not only
in a large republic will
you have a better choice
of candidates, but because
the candidates have to appeal
each to a large number of
people, that they are less likely
to come to power through shady dealings
and you're mostly likely
to get the best folks.
It must be confessed that in
this, as in most other cases,
there is a mean on both
sides of which inconveniences
will be found to lie.
So you say hey look, there
is, as in all things,
there is kind of a moderate middle ground.
By enlarging too much
the number of electors,
you render the representatives
to little acquainted
with all their local circumstances
and lesser interests,
as by reducing it too
much, you render him unduly
attached to these and too
little fit to comprehend
and pursue great and national objects.
The federal Constitution
forms a happy combination
in this respect.
The great and aggregate
interests being referred to
the national, the local and particular
to the state legislatures.
So what he's saying is that
the Constitution offers
this really nice balance here.
You can have the people
participating at the national level
who are interested in the
great and aggregate interests
and it's okay if those folks
aren't completely attached
to what is happening at
home, the local interests.
In fact, he'd probably prefer
that they're not attached
too much to the local interests,
but the local interests
could be focused at
the state legislatures,
which the Constitution provides for.
The other point of
difference, so once again,
he is referring to the
difference between a republican
government and a pure democracy.
The greater number of
citizens in the extent
of territory which may be
brought within the compass
of republican than of
democratic government.
So it's that point that he believes
the republican government
can better govern
a large population than a pure democracy
and it is this circumstance principally
which renders the factious
combinations less to be dreaded
in the former than in the latter.
So he's saying because a
republican model can govern
over more people, it
better addresses this issue
of factious combinations.
The smaller the society,
the fewer probably will be
the distinct parties and
interests composing it.
The fewer the distinct
parties and interests,
the more frequently will a
majority be found of the same
party, and the smaller
the number of individuals
composing a majority and
the smaller the compass
within which they are
placed, the more easily
will they concert and execute
their plans of oppression.
Extend the sphere and you
take in a greater variety
of parties and interests.
You make it less probable
that a majority of the whole
will have a common motive to invade
the rights of other citizens.
What Madison is saying here
is if you have too small
of a society, you're not going
to have enough pluralism,
you're not going to have
enough points of view,
that it will be easy because
people will be very aligned
for a majority to take over and infringe
on the rights of a minority.
So he is very pro pluralism here.
He wants to see a large society
with many different views
because he says if you
have a large society
with many different views,
with many different parties,
so to speak, well then it's less likely
that one party can just take
over and infringe on the rights
of other people.
This is the exact opposite of
what Brutus one argues for.
Brutus one argues that
pluralism is a bad thing,
that people are just going to
be bickering the whole time
and decisions aren't going to be made.
Brutus one argues that in a
republic, people should be
of roughly the same
opinion, to have roughly
the same interests while
here in Federalist number 10,
Madison is arguing that no,
pluralism is a good thing,
it is a check on an overbearing faction,
it is a check on majority rule.
Hence, it clearly appears
that the same advantage
which a republic has over
a democracy in controlling
the effects of faction
is enjoyed by a large
over a small republic,
is enjoyed by the Union
over the states composing it.
So the big picture of Federalist number 10
is how do you control faction?
And faction is really
about how do you control
a majority faction
that's trying to control
everyone else and trying
to oppress everyone else.
Madison makes the argument that one,
through a republican system,
you're more like to do this,
by having a representative government.
And then if you have that,
you want to make it larger
rather than smaller so that
you have a pluralist society,
so you have many points
of view and you don't have
one group being able to dominate.
And in order to have that larger society,
the Union is more favorable over having
13 independent, sovereign states.
In the extent and proper
structure of the Union,
therefore, we behold a republican remedy
for the diseases most incident
to republican government
and according to the degree
of pleasure and pride
we feel in being republicans
ought to be our zeal
and cherishing the spirit and supporting
the character of Federalists.